chaque jour il converse avec elle se
confie
quand je vais aller voir papa tout à
l'heure
et les réponses qu'il obtient sont
parfois criante de vérité
a toujours eu cette attitude de comme
s'il était meilleur que les autres
ça c'est vraiment dingue parce que tous
ceux qui connaissent mon père dirait ça
de lui
je vous cite cette dame qui dit être
recouverte dans la d'un seul au pied
d'un arbre pour pouvoir revenir à la
terre de manière la plus simple possible
ce qui ça c'est de se c'est une phrase
un peu à la Victor Hugo pour parler d'un
nouveau processus c'est une nouvelle
demande ça s'appelle j'ai trouvé un
champignon non
c'est redevenir
redevenir de l'humus exactement
yes vas-y ma petite gueule pas de
problème on se tient au courant
de remise
les gens ne savent pas ça
vous êtes nombreux à me demander comment
je trouve le temps d'écrire alors que je
suis ministre voilà le message que vous
avez posté sur votre réseau Twitter ce
matin Bruno Le Maire ce qui veut dire
quand même que beaucoup de Français
s'étonnent que depuis votre nomination à
Bercy vous avez publié 5 livres dont
deux romans soit 1312 pages c'est plus
qu'un écrivain à plein temps Michel
Houellebecq comme la calculer le
journaliste de Libération Sylvain Chazot
certes c'est deux fois moins que Proust
pour sa recherche du temps perdu merci
de la comparaison le ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Le Maire l'a dit on
leur demande dès lors que les prix des
matières premières ont baissé de rouvrir
des négociations tous les salariés qui
sont un peu au dessus qui doivent aussi
pouvoir bénéficier d'une augmentation
écrire c'est un moyen de fuir votre
quotidien au ministère à Bercy d'abord
ces interrogations légitimes c'est pour
ça que j'ai voulu y répondre je
comprends que les Français puissent se
poser à la question suite la réponse
elle est très simple cet ouvrage c'est
10 ans de travail
même si vous passez toutes vos vie à
lire des livres vous en lirez maximum
quelques dizaines de milliers
4 peuvent lire des dizaines ou des
centaines de milliers de livres en
quelques minutes ou secondes
donc ce n'est qu'une question de temps
avant que ces modèles soient meilleurs
que nous dans pratiquement tous les
domaines
dans ce roman il y a pas que la
politique la dépression ou une fugue il
y a aussi des scènes très sensuelles on
peut même les qualifier des rôties je
cite par exemple Julia tu viens Oscar je
suis dilaté comme jamais et disant ces
mots elle avait un visage d'ange si elle
était folle d'amour moi j'étais en
extase vous savez évidemment que c'est
ces passages vont être remarqués pas que
par mois mais il était hors de question
de se censurer
ce que vous donne le roman contrairement
à des textes politiques c'est la liberté
je rappelle que s'il existe un sujet sur
lequel il y a consensus en France c'est
précisément sur l'immigration bref
bon ça veut rien dire on va pas se
mentir Elisabeth borne a présenté sa
feuille de route ou de des routes c'est
selon alors peut-être que comme pellet
vous allez faire vous aussi votre entrée
dans le dictionnaire c'est ce qui s'est
passé au Brésil officiellement Pelé
devenu le synonyme d'excellence au
Brésil alors ça c'est vraiment c'est
énorme c'est une belle reconnaissance
reste à fixer la date du départ
puisqu'il est acquis qu'Emmanuel Macron
et Elisabeth borne ne finiront pas l'été
ensemble c'est possible crédible
crédible c'est bon
migrants Navy regard caméra cette
succession de mots clés censés générer
une image par intelligence artificielle
mais cette photo est bien réelle le but
ici n'est pas de tromper mais d’alerter
car cette vidéo est tirée de la nouvelle
campagne de la Croix Rouge autre exemple
avec cette photo d'une fillette en
Ukraine ces images d'immeubles
effondrées en Turquie ou de sans-abris à
Paris sont certifiés sans ya la réalité
ça ne s'invente pas rappelle
l'association
au cœur de ses vies les thermomètres
affichent des températures record pour
la saison 38 degrés à l'ombre cet
après-midi une situation qui inquiète
les habitants pourtant habitué à vivre
des été très chauds
on avait des mois d'avril qui avec nos
critères actuels sera considérés comme
frais voir froid et on voit vraiment les
cils l'effet du réchauffement à partir
des années fin des années 90-2000 avec
des mois d'avril de globalement en
moyenne de plus en plus chaud elle est
ici
Ryan je suis là pour vous aider et j'ai
besoin que vous restiez calme un deux
trois je tire je tire je tire 1 2 3
quand les jeunes sportifs mettent la
tête sous l'eau parfois volontairement
dans des exercices
[Musique]
les autorités sanitaires leur recommande
une douche savonnée pour éviter des
problèmes de peau
c'est bon pour vous
1 2 3 allez on continue on continue on
continue
[Musique]
ah ça y est tu es libéré
pourtant à l'idée de se baigner dans le
fleuve après les JO ils sont tous très
enthousiastes
ça fait toujours du bien de pouvoir se
rafraîchir l'été surtout avec les
canicules qui vont arriver ça peut
toujours être bien et puis c'est fun
c'est ludique voilà maintenant vous
montez sur la scène et vous allez
derrière le pupitre monsieur le
Président
le pupitre
ça reste au pupitre
[Rires]
alors regardez le gris ça vous dira il
nous fait pipi à long terme voilà
bonjour monsieur ou madame je ne sais
pas c'est d'un ce sont des lémuriens en
fait
lors d'une réunion il avait dans les
mains une fiche qui détaille le
protocole à suivre vous écrire en gras
vous entrez dans la pièce et vous dites
bonjour vous vous asseyez sur votre
siège vous remercier les participants et
vous repartez
[Musique]
arrête arrête
non mais tu viens en témoin de Jéhovah
[Applaudissements]
qui est tragique aussi cruelle mais
extrêmement réussie contrairement à
Bruno Le Maire là celui-là je l'ai fini
[Rires]
du début de la phrase
non
j'aurais rien à [__] c'est pas sérieux
je suis désolé les gars elle est trop
petit